- I am so excited to meet you!
- I'm excited to meet you as well.
- I know you know about the
tweet from like a decade ago.
But like, I stand by the
tweet, like even right now.
Like this is my question, Kyle.
For all humans out there looking.
Are there more people that look
like you where you're from?
(all laugh)
Just asking for a friend.
No, that Men's Journals...
I'll tell you what.
I think I was at the dentist or...
I was somewhere, and all of a sudden
I looked over and I was
like, who looks like this?
And just walking around, it's so rude.
You are a beautiful man.
That's all I'm saying.
And I know you're
happily married 25 years.
No weirdness, just saying
you're a very beautiful man.
But I wish you could be here
to see our Christmas set, though.
We did this for you, Kyle.
We did this for you.
- It looks beautiful.
I didn't wanna interrupt you,
'cause I don't wanna
interrupt an intro like that.
But I've got something.
I got something for you,
and if maybe you could
put this under the tree.
- Okay.
- Here's one of your people now.
Would you come put that
under the tree please?
- Okay.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Yes, I'll take it.
- So they can put that under there.
- Is it like Mary Poppins?
Is like another you gonna to
come out of the box? (laughs)
I'm just kidding.
Just kidding.